we have a saying in asgard  where there are wolf's ears wolves teeth  and ear  it's a trap  he's lying just playing games at me for  a sec loki my ears are sharp too  here's the deal  fugitive variant's been killing our  minutemen  haven't been able to find them  so let's bring in an expert  that's me the criminal could be anywhere  anytime  [Applause]  you got to be careful anything we do can  impact the course of history you get  that okay  the timekeepers are monitoring every  aspect of this case  trusting this man is not a good idea  no one bad is ever truly bad  and no one good is ever truly good  [Music]  this isn't about you right  [Music]  okay  i believe stupidly  [Music]  you can be whatever you want to be  even someone good  by the way i should have an equal amount  of security this is insulting you just  can't help yourself  [Music]  you